what up guys it never fails to surprise
me
how awful instagram influencers are
and i feel like this story really sums
up everything that i hate about
instagram
uh it's all these fake influencers
living fake lives
nothing's real the house is rented the
lambo's rented
and they make you feel bad because
you're working your nine to five you got
more money than they do you don't even
know that
but you're looking at them like wow he's
got a lambo she bought a lamborghini oh
my god
how come everyone has lambos oh
incredible
everyone buys their lambo no they're all
rented
the house is rented the lambo's rented
the lifestyle
isn't real i keep telling you guys that
but i want to start highlighting it so
this is the first in a series maybe
um horrible instagram or something like
that all right so to cover this real
quick
this traitor uh he calls himself a wolf
traitor claims he can't repay his mom
750 000
because he has to maintain his social
media in an extraordinary rant about his
love of clothes
and watches okay so let's break this
down
this is the person we're talking about
today tyson schultz
better known as asx wolff on instagram
he had 15 000 followers before he
deleted his social media
following the fallout of all this but
here's what happened
he had a bunch of subway shops that he
owned with his mom his mom spent her
life savings basically half a million
dollars
on a subway shop to own with her son now
the son managed everything and put it in
his
own name rather than in his mom's name
so she invests her life savings
this guy's mom's life savings to be
clear he keeps it under his own name
finally she files a lawsuit now at the
same time that's happening this guy's
trying to project an
image on instagram that he's this baller
he's living this crazy lifestyle right
here's a few pictures from his now
deleted instagram uh
he's riding speed boats you know he's
got a helicopter he's just
living the jet set lifestyle all while
not paying his mom
okay so he's posting this lifestyle and
then trying to sell
stock tips alongside of it his excuse
basically is
the reason i can afford all this stuff
is because i'm an expert stock trader
okay look this is the stuff you would
post bought me a new toy trading has
been great for the first half of 2018
well january anyway so he's saying i
bought this lamborghini
okay and then he tries to sell basically
stock tips on top of that 500
for this tip because it has the bones to
make five to 10x money
so that's the backdrop to this story
okay
he's saying he's got a great lifestyle
whatever whatever meanwhile he's not
paying his mom
allegedly so finally she sues because
she realizes okay i'm not getting paid
she invested apparently in 2013
500 grand and never got ownership so she
sues him
and the court rules in her favor they
say you got to pay your mom back 750
000 and this
ladies and gentlemen is when the house
of cards
begins to fall allegedly after he was
told to pay 750
000 to his mother he says he doesn't
have it
he doesn't have the money in fact he
says he's on
unemployment benefits with a declared
income of 44 cents
a fortnight now if you're like me and
you don't know what a fortnite is
you have to look it up i'll save you the
time it means every two weeks
he's basically making a dollar a month
now that's probably not true he's just
probably trying to get away from
you know paying his mom but isn't it
funny that this stock guru who's like
posing in front of the
helicopter you know he's saying oh i
bought the lambo bro you're not making a
dollar a month
and at the court hearing where basically
his mom and him are fighting it out for
her
life savings he's like no mom i can't
pay you back your life savings
apparently uh he released some more
damning evidence
he said that uh he needs 2500 a week
to keep maintaining his lifestyle for
the image
for the gram dude you got to do it for
the gram you can't be an influencer on a
on a dollar a month
you got to have 2500 a week mr schultz
said
he liked to dine out and buy clothes
because quote
that is what social media is about
[Music]
listen guys we've ruined a generation
we've taught them that image means
everything when actually it couldn't
matter less
being owning a lambo having the image
doesn't make you a better trader
but ultimately it doesn't matter this
guy's not actually trying to trade he's
just trying to get
sell stock tips and he's doing that by
pretending to be ballin
if i go and buy a watch tomorrow a 50
000 watch i have to keep maintaining the
lifestyle for the image for the selling
of the stuff so he's admitting hey
the only way i can sell is if i pretend
that pretend that my life is so great
meanwhile you're not even paying your
own mother this is
what's so bad about instagram
and these influencers who their whole
life is built around
and their success and brand is all built
around
being something that they're not and
also
projecting a false lifestyle onto a
bunch of
followers who are impressionable who
were like well hey how do i become like
asx
wolf what a baller but i think the good
news and what you can always kind of
rely on is
these people they never really get away
with it forever they may get away with
it for a little while it's like dan
balzerian right
dan molzarian did this he he did it much
better than this guy
but it's falling apart and it's falling
apart for this guy too
i mean it turns out the lamborghini that
he said he bought do you remember that
he said bought me a new toy yeah turns
out it was a rental
despite him saying that he paid more
than 300 000
for the car apparently in the transcript
he said he only owned the number plate
[Music]
the only part of the lambo he owned was
the license plate
and i'll just add this in because it's
some good shot and freud
dude that lamborghini that he had was
actually seized earlier this year
because he was speeding
around uh australia and i think he was
taking
video of himself speeding but yeah his
his
his car got repossessed earlier this
year now that basically covers the daily
mail side of the story
but there's more to it guys because
there's a twitter user by the handle of
stock swami that has been following
tyson schultz for a long time and he's
been basically
busting open this case way before it
ever hit the presses or anything like
that
so i got to give a quick shout out to
him because he's done some great job in
documenting the stuff
worth noting right at the top is that uh
stock swami got the permission of
tyson's family to share this information
because even though it's public
information it's also
sort of personal information as well now
with that out of the way
let's get into the most i think damning
part of this uh whole thread it's a long
thread
i'll link it below so you can go follow
stock swami but
one of the big things is that someone
from the subway reached out the area
manager
okay of the subway franchises uh they
reached out and apparently
she was the manager for four years i
currently work with his wife
not an ex-wife because he won't sign the
papers he did have
five stores and a massive empire so he
was like he owned a bunch of franchises
and threw all that away left his misses
with jack
and over two hundred thousand dollars of
debt which we are slowly paying back and
rebuilding yes he left her with a
million dollar business
but he left her in a lot of debt he
refuses to see his daughter because he's
too busy partying
i've seen the messages heard the calls
and dealt with him firsthand
it's up to him how he lives and
continues on with his life but it's
all for attention and social media if
he's happy then so be it but there's no
way he can say he left his wife better
off
or it was good for her because that is
complete [ __ ]
the man i used to idolize and looked up
to very quickly turned into a man you
wouldn't want to know so this is crazy i
mean
so not only the the mom's involved
the wife's involved it gets really
personal and nasty there's bad checks
going around
the point is this guys what's the lesson
the lesson is that instagram
is not real life and you can throw away
your real life for a fake life this is
sort of the story of
tyson it's the story of a man who wanted
fame
so badly that he gave up a successful
business and actually successful
you know relationships all for the fame
for the clout
the gram so that's basically it i hope
you've learned something here
if you have someone you'd like to
nominate for a horrible instagram video
let me know
looking for all fakes and frauds because
this stuff's out of control man we got
to call it out
and don't forget to smash like and
subscribe
thank you
[Music]
us
[Music]
comes along